on Thursday and their victory against
Oregon all the 12 minutes the starters
[Applause]
already with three balls in or as the
game progresses he coaches going to make
sure that he gets over them to help
defense to stop that path to the cutter
Edwards again
here's Edwards
diandra hunter averaging 15 point two
points per game in the regular season he
led Virginia scoring Edwards cocaine
gone big against the Boilermakers mercy
at Purdue right now whose Edwards off
the ball or in the pick-and-roll to get
him a little action he has to get going
[Applause]
never shoot the gap on the shooter when
you have two screens coming he gave back
to three he just knocked that head where
it's a long race
[Applause]
nothing but net East his men stop just
to come in when you have your teammate
having it offers a good position
[Applause]
position this is a threat to drive it or
knock it down put that pass right in the
pocket here's Edwards for the answer
[Applause]
mouths word Purdue needs to stick to
what works for them either head Edwards
climb or go inside Edwards for three yes
[Applause]
Three's then you may double-team him the
bigs have to be ready to slip the
pick-and-roll right away and have their
hands ready to catch
here's Edwards for the leap
[Applause]